si vous roulaient sans casque sans
papiers voilà à quoi ressemblera votre
moto cet amas de métal c'est le résultat
de la destruction d'une dizaine de deux
roues saisis par les forces de l'ordre
un signal fort envoyé aux motards hors
la loi souvent impliqués dans les
accidents
les chiffres sont effrayants n'a plus 25
% d'accidents en 2017 en martinique
beaucoup de deux roues il faut le dire
et puis il ya un signal par rapport à
l'autorité au respect des règles
notamment parce que chacun peut le
constater il y a encore beaucoup trop de
motards qui roulent sans assurance sans
casque avec des plaques pacifié voir
sans plaque du tout pour changer les
mentalités les contrôles routiers seront
plus nombreux cette année les motards
sans assurance en plaques
d'immatriculation avec des véhicules
maquiller seront ciblés sont des
comportements qui ont pour objectif
manifeste d'échapper aux sanctions
prévues par la loi en matière
d'infractions au code de la route mais
également d'échapper à l'interpellation
parler ça revient ou en tout cas les lie
à l'identification par les services de
police à la suite de la commission de
faits beaucoup plus graves tels que des
vols à main armée notamment l'objectif
est de rétablir une autorité forte et
faire diminuer le nombre d'accidents
l'an dernier 30 personnes sont mortes
sur une route 12 étaient des motards